Kevin can you shut up yeah I think he
got a great night's sleep
five hours and I feel awesome after a
visit like five hours feels like 13 days
Joe Jonas is bachelor party was
obviously pretty epic but would we
expect anything else the Joe Broz spent
a few days getting lit in Ibiza and
celebrate Joe and then proved they are
total rock stars going to an interview
with Capital FM right after it's a
pleasure
this is really really nice you've just
come back from my beta and surprisingly
you're looking all incredibly good
working you play at this stage in our
life in career we figure out the balance
yeah work really hard she can play even
harder
Joe is surrounded by all of his brothers
and several pals including his DNC
bandmates Cole and their friend Jordan
McGraw Joe said this about the bash to
quote the boy the boys the boys
incredible weekend full of celebration
in Ibiza love you all a hashtag bath
life
they enjoyed time on this yacht looks
like they played some soccer and were
especially obsessed with this shot of
Joe and Nick enjoying cigars
Joe and Sofie tied the knot earlier this
month in a quickie Vegas wedding ring
happily married most recently Joe in
Vegas with sophie Turner how was that
was lit and by now we all know Diplo
livestream the entire thing I love Diplo
but he loves his gram more than a 13
year old he posts every five seconds he
literally like live stream with Dogface
filters yeah
it was like we just laughed we loved it
we thought was ridiculous and I just
loved that he was walking into the
chaplain he's like gonna hit this
wedding real quick and Diplo responded
to that in the best way
posting this article screenshot to
Instagram quote the only thing that
ruined the wedding was your fit
to which Joe commented with this emoji
hilarious and Sophie also weighed in on
the Diplo of it all friday morning
telling port a edit quote it would have
been better if no one had known but i
actually think it was funny no word if
Diplo will score an invite to Joe and
Sophie's second wedding et has learned
it'll be a more formal celebration in
France in June it means so much to have
him here it's just like the best support
the best person to calm me down and keep
you calm and if I end up crying I have a
shoulder to cry on so it's good I'm so
happy thank you all right guys I am
obsessed with all things Joe and Sophie
I think they're just the cutest
if you agree make sure that you keep it
locked on all things 80 until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and bye for now